the suits backless and the Cape really
covers up that really sort of sexy or
exposed part of the Mysterio costume hi
i'm jake gyllenhaal I play Mysterio in
the exciting new spider-man movie far
from home and this is my seat great job
I'm old school people are like dude stop
using the mouth like why are you doing
this space bar I'm like you understand I
still drag and drop man I don't do
shortcuts
this is mr. Beck okay I just need to
stop this for for a minute we shot maybe
40 takes in this cuz every single time
we would join up in this one shot right
here every time I put my hand out to
shake his he started to laugh and then I
couldn't stop I think what I remember is
that they were passing around watermelon
as a snack and Tom and I just we were
waiting for the set up the shot and so
he was eating water my I was eating part
know and then we did that like being
around our arms and we like ate each
other's watermelon in a creepy way and
that set it off and then we had to be
serious after that moment and then it
could be gonna get serious the whole
spider-man costume so Jay what are you
doing you handled yourself well out
there today so what you did with the
tower Thanks
still make me laugh I see okay then
morning stable orbits within black holes
so there's no hologram there and we were
filming and if you notice you can see
the experience of everybody in the MCU
because literally none of us are looking
in the same direction and I really am
NOT if we go back you can see where I'm
looking my eyes I have no idea what I'm
looking at and I'm just there just
churning around in a really weird way
you look back on it look I'm just tom
knows exactly what he's looking at the
science division not me technical nope
reaches no idea
elementals versions of them exist that's
now that myths are real
I moved the hologram around but I
clearly did that so badly that it's not
in the movie anymore I'm just staring at
it they're like just talk and move your
hands around a little bit and I was like
yeah okay yeah so they're called
elementals they're from another and
they're like whoa that cut like you're
moving hands as much I was like read
they're called elements like just maybe
a little more it was I was horrible at
it it's a great work of our imagination
and then the incredible work of all the
CGI artists and visual effects they were
born in stable orbits within black holes
creatures forms from the primary
elements air water fire earth the
science division had a technical name we
just called them elementals the first
creature to attack they see is the water
elemental when Peters classes in Venice
whole thing about Quentin Beck is that
he has gone through this dimensional
rift and chased one of these elementals
actually the earth elemental downed
earth and the fire elemental destroyed
his earth he was a soldier there and he
finds himself here totally unsure of
what is going on
he doesn't know spider-man or
spider-man's powers he surprised that
he's just a kid before he even walks in
Nick Fury's said you know this guy is
really powerful and you can do all the
stuff and he's gonna help us fight then
he sees him he's like what you don't
want any part of this there's a lot to
Quentin Beck there are many things that
inspire him and many things that inspire
his superpowers and where they come from
and his history and how similar it is to
spider-man's
I like you Peter a good kid or a
three-three is is the earth that
mysterious from and earth-616 is a earth
that they are on in alternate universes
there is symmetry which is an actual
scientific sort of idea there are
cultural things and things that are that
he doesn't always get or understand
obviously it doesn't have a lot of time
or to get another outfit really you guys
do have sarcasm on this earth right
versions of them exists across our
mythologies turns out the myths are real
like Thorin Laura was a medicine now I
study him in my physics class it's not
in the scene you don't see it but I was
like Thor those types of things that I
was constantly questioning you know do I
know what a popsicle is that was I don't
know these myths what threats they first
materialized on my earth many years ago
I was part of the last battalion life
trying to stop them
all we did was delay the inevitable it
took a little getting used to this suit
the chest plate is really hard I cannot
move my arms like one way or the other
sometimes every shooting scenes be
shooting something like this and it be
literally like a disco ball there are
these accents like in the shoulder area
that I put a whole other layer on
underneath that's with like has green
sequins almost so that it shines through
in certain areas which is really cool
and when you put on Cape it's really
cool
you have to be careful of people walking
behind you because I have been almost
decapitated by that it's like 40 pounds
that cave
it's like Game of Thrones times 14 it's
backless the suit so the cape really
covers up that really sort of sexy or
expose part part of the Mysterio costume
the elementals are here now attacking
the same coordinates our satellites
confirm it we have one mission kill it
we shot this scene in the London tunnels
like under the Tower Bridge which is
pretty incredible down there it has so
much history so a lot of times you see
these scenes in their shot on stages and
this is that it was beautiful a damn
you're coming with us
it's a fury this all seems like big time
you know huge superhero kind of stuff
and I mean I'm just a friendly
neighborhood spider-man sir it's please
you've been to space well that was one
of the first scenes I shot in the movie
thanks for checking out my scene
breakdown catch spider-man far from home
theaters July 2nd get your tickets on
Fandango
[Music]